- Meeting new people is the spice of life,
but sometimes, you look
all over the kitchen,
and you don't know
where the spice rack is.
You need someone to show you the way.
So, I'm gonna find two people
and demand that they hang out
with each other all day.
Let's see how it goes.
(mischievous music)
- Do you like meeting new people?
- Yes, of course.
- I do!
I'm from Australia, so I'm
getting to know all new people.
- Yeah, sometimes.
- Of course.
- I'm antisocial.
- People are wonderful,
as long as they're nice.
- If I found someone random for you
to hang out with all day, would you do it?
- Well, I would have to
approve that randomness.
- Uh, no.
- Right now, no.
- I think so, yeah.
- Great, we got our first person!
- I'll be fine.
If they're open to sitting
down in the sun for a while
at my job and then going
to party with me then
they'll see how fun I am at that scene.
- We just came to where we're supposed to
meet up with Dustin.
(ding)
He didn't have a working
cellphone here in the US.
We'll see.
Time to wait.
(rhythmic, languid music)
(beep)
Well, unfortunately our first
guy we found didn't show up,
so he had to get on the bus and go.
We're back to square one.
How would you feel about a
random stranger joining you
for everything you do
for the rest of the day?
- I would totally do that.
- I have Caitlyn and Gary
who have agreed to hang out
with each other all day.
- I've agreed almost.
- Hi.
- Hi, Caitlyn.
- You from Australia?
- I am from Australia.
- Cool, what are you doing here?
- I'm a filmmaker and my
film's playing in Shriekfest.
- What's your movie about?
- It's a horror-comedy about two girls who
decide to do a blood
pact over a sleepover,
and then they cut their
hands, can't stop bleeding.
- Anyway, listen, I can't stay.
(beep)
- I've got Caitlyn and Bree,
game to hang out all day.
Go ahead and meet each other!
- Hi, Caitlyn.
- Bree!
- Lovely to meet you.
- You too. Oh, this is easier.
- I'm going to the Museum of Death.
- Yes!
- Are you happy to come to that?
- I would absolutely go with you to that.
- Perfect, and then I'm
going to Shriekfest later
to see some films play.
- So are you guys best friends yet?
- Yeah!
- Pretty much.
(inspirational music)
- Alright , guys, have a great day.
- Thanks.
(upbeat rock music)
- We went to the Museum of Death.
- Oh, my gosh, I'm so excited.
- Yes!
- We met that lovely Australian girl
and her American friend.
- Australia, nah.
(laughs)
- And, you know how to embalm a body.
- Yes, that was very interesting.
There was the cult room,
which was awesome.
- The cult room.
We're just finished!
Somebody got a shirt.
- I got a bag!
Then we went to Shriekfest.
- Shriekfest!
- Opening night, wait..
who's that guy behind you?
- This fuckin' guy. (laughs)
Fun day, though.
- Yeah, and we got
pictures on the red carpet.
That was great.
- Yeah!
What we gonna do?
- We're about to see a horror movie.
- From where?
- From Spain!
- We're about to see how
Spain scares the crap
outta their people.
That was a good movie.
- It was well made.
Bye, guys, we had a
really nice time tonight.
- Shriekfest.
You called an Uber and I
- Yeah, yeah I called it.
- stood there to make sure that
you weren't just, like, kidnapped.
- And you told the guy,
like, "Get her home safe!"
- Yeah, and that dude looked
at me like I was joking.
And I was like, "No, no. I
need to make sure she's, like,
alive tomorrow, people.
She's nice, I like her."
- Okay, so we just got two
random strangers to hang out
all day and they had a great time,
and they're, like,
basically best friends now.
So you should go meet a
stranger on the street,
and tell them you're doing
whatever you're doing
and see how it goes.
(upbeat rock music)